محمد ثروت وابنه يخطفان القلوب في ليله
الزمن الجميل مياده الحناوي تلتقي جمهورها
السعودي لاول مره على ارض المملكه مصالحه
بين نوال الزغبي ومحمد رمضان في الميوريكس
دورت ومحمد عبد العزيز يشعل الجدل في
اهداء جائزه النار بالنار اليكم الابرز في
اسبوع
[موسيقى]
شهدت جده الاسبوع الماضي ليله الزمن
الجميل وحظيت بتفاعل واسع على منصات
التواصل في السعوديه والعالم العربي
واحيتها مطربه الاجيال السوريه مياده
الحناوي التي التقت الجمهور السعودي لاول
مره على ارض المملكه
واحيا ليله الزمن الجميل ايضا الفنانه
المصريه القديره عفاف راضي وشاركتها
ابنتها الغناء على المسرح
[موسيقى]
كما قبل الفنان المصري محمد ثروت بحفاوه
كبيره في ليله الزمن الجميل وكان من ابرز
مشاهد هذه الليله تاثر الفنان المصري
بمفاجاه ابنه الذي لا زال في طور التعافي
من مرض تعرض له مؤخرا بالغناء له ابن بويا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مشهد حقق تفاعلا كبيرا على منصات التواصل
في مصر والسعوديه والعالم العربي وتالق
الاب والابن معا في غناء كدا يا قلبي
لشيرين عبد الوهاب
[موسيقى]
عن حاجه
اليوم نطلق الشعار الجديد لموسم الرياض
بهويه ابتكاريه ورؤيه مستدامه وفي
السعوديه ايضا اعلنت تركي ال الشيخ عن
الهويه الجديده لموسم الرياض الذي ستنطلق
فعالياته اواخر تشرين الاول اكتوبر المقبل
ومنها فعاليات رياضيه وفنيه ستقام لاول
مره كنزاع الحزام موسم الرياض للملاكمه
عام فئه الوزن الثقيل وعالم باربي وقلع
الديزني احتفالا بالذكرى المئويه الاولى
لتاسيسها ومتحف خاص بكريستيانو رونالدو
والعديد من الحفلات الموسيقيه والعروض
المسرحيه العربيه والعالميه
والى لبنان الذي شهد حفل توزيع جوائز
الميوريكس دور للعام 2023 حيث تم تكريم
العديد من نجوم الغناء والتمثيل
اللبنانيين والعرب ومن ابرز المكرمين
الفنانه اللبنانيه هدى حداد شقيقه فيروز
[موسيقى]
كما منحت جوائز نيويورك زوري
للمروان خوري ميريام فارس زياد برجي نوال
الزغبي وعبير نعمه التي منحت جائزتين
اهدتهما لابنتها يارا التي صعدت الى
جانبها على المسرح في لفته مؤثره
على امل انه انا فخورها فيك اليوم ومن
المغنيين الذين فازوا بجوائز نيوركس دور
هذا العام المصري احمد سعد والسوري ناصيف
زيتون والعراقيه رحمه رياض
انه اني اتكرم للمره الرابعه بالميراكلس
وفاز العديد من الممثلين اللبنانيين
والعرب بجوائز الميوريكس دور هذا العام
ومن ضمن الفنانين اللبنانيين جورج خباز
وورد الخال والفنانين السوريين قيس الشيخ
نجيب وكاريس بشار والفنانه المصريه هاله
صدقي و الفنان المصري محمد رمضان وكان من
ابرز مشاهد هذا العام المصالحه بين رمضان
والمطربه اللبنانيه نوال الزغبي بعد سجال
سابق بينهما على وسائل الاعلام ومنصات
التواصل انا بحبك قوي وانت فنان كبير فعلا
وبعد فوز مسلسل النار بالنار الذي يسلط
الضوء على العلاقه الشائكه بين السوريين
واللبنانيين بجائزه افضل مسلسل لبناني
بدراما المشتركه عبر صحفيون ومتابعون
لبنانيون عن امتعاضهم من اهداء مخرج
المسلسل السوري محمد عبد العزيز الجائزه
لروح الرئيس الراحل حافظ الاسد في تدوينه
له عبر فيسبوك ودعوا لمقاطعه المخرج
السوري وعدم التعامل معه في لبنان